[Applause]
[Music]
and I'm sorry we're late and it happens
man she talked about how we're supposed
to be in the car at 6:45 I'm like all
right Oh tell me my dumb ass is sitting
in the car waiting until 7:15
oh okay when I track my wife down 20
minutes later she's stepping up the damn
shower talking about can I help you see
that's crazy right there
wait I looked this woman in the eye I
said bitch you told me 6:45 oh you said
that yes then I laid it out would you
say a bitch though hmm
he said bitch yeah
don't play dayz man just tell me what
exactly it's like say what you mean mean
what you say it's like last week man we
going out to dinner right I'm like where
do you want to go she's like you decide
oh I'm like all right Outback Steakhouse
she like nah mm-hmm like straight up
Chili's she's like you know no Darrell I
named seven more rescued no I finally
said tailors the place I know she wants
to grab the first lady's right trying to
look at me she said if that's where you
want to go no she didn't go that's where
I want to go Darrell I looked my woman
in the eye socket and I told her
straight out I just said it man baby I'm
gonna take a back to the kitchen insure
the dishwasher hey Darrell
yeah baby I want a kitchen island just
like the one upstairs you gonna get it
too
I love you I love you I said bitch if
you wanted to go to Taylor's just tell
her brother you want to go with Taylor
you said oh hell yeah man I laid it out
right I says I said
I said bitch I'm the man of the house
you say bitch though mm-hmm you caught
your wife a bitch oh yeah so she's like
why don't you win a movie we both like
no she did not spare 25 minutes in the
goddamn blockbuster Craig I looked this
woman in her optic stems and I says you
said that but you said bitch though yep
hey honey Craig just give me the
neighborhood tour so then she's like I
didn't know we'd be doing so much
walking no I'm like I didn't tell you to
wear those shoes she said don't raise
your voice at me
what Dan row I'll look this woman dead
in the windows of her soul I said
I said
I
[Music]
you